this can't be good surface tension
Oh lengthen Oh
where is he where is that so they all
think they're so smart for being a but
that's where they got is that okay yes
she's a need help badly Oh
she says
this is weird that I'm like say lying
around yeah guess I should get this guy
okay again here
let's kill by the competition you know
now this is not like that
that's your sure alright get in here
oh look there's a nice rock formation
right here crap not right here
or the Helen
okay see any alien up Oh what is this
- over there
perfect
sure how to heat them out of themselves
they still like to mow over there oh
yeah what is this my god that's just
what I needed
this is so weird isn't really I'm like
any app like you've ever played
chin up Kenneth jump exactly
Jesus
crap okay I got to go in there's my
health kiss or something
oh absolutely I gotta turn this okay
change this you made all that juice
sorry
I'm someplace more long-range I thinks
is long-range right combine any a lens
on it gonna I guess there's no aliens
here yeah I'm a common on that way
oh right Yeah right
tap-tap-tap
okay
okay what the heck
wait what is this doing
maybe success
how's that
okay so that's what it's got to be doing
holy smokes I don't know what those
aliens are whoa whoa
okay I know where I am but I have got to
get out of this water
ah this is so weird
who is messaging
let's take a bit wowza I cannot get a
reply to this
Oh chick dances yeah okay well I guess
I'll end this here for now right it's
gotta be a new section right here okay
Ellen's here thanks for watching y'all
died yeah okay you crazy [ __ ] okay
it is a boy psycho Baba now we're back
in this game
I love the background changing because
it actually means like that when I first
saw it I did the background change it
was like a shoe level and it showed that
shitty level and I thought the whole
game was gonna be like that but I'm
happy it changes um and we're in this
pipe okay we'll just see how it goes you
know let's just take it easy
you know like pipes are generally safe
you know for the most part you can't
really get hurt in a pipe
I'm not less water flowing through it I
guess but yeah no okay one is that pill
what the f okay lower canals s way what
the hell is that
they're headcrabs wait hold on up get
get get get get not onion is the P none
none okay I don't think interesting out
here I didn't think so okay I don't
think so what is this how could I jump
and get that we'll say let's just say
real quick you know before we do
anything irrational okay um ya know the
good thing is I save okay what do not
know it you hear that
surebut charges up just about to go down
you know what I'm saying brothers see a
headcrab out there okay that makes it
easy I guess I can't do anything in here
you know what they say you know what
they say like you don't mess with the
tiger if you can get the milk for free
okay and that's exactly how I feel about
all this right now it's like I don't
mess with the tiger if I could just like
milk the Tigers nipples when he's
sleeping holy [ __ ]
you [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
hello sir
oh [ __ ] - hi Joe I like when they scream
because that means they're paying
attention you know surface access okay I
have no idea how to get there all right
I guess I guess back in the hole you
know sure not to go there
okay you know one more time we're going
to try this one more time maybe I got to
press X real quick nope nope that is not
real what I'm thinking it's not real
okay
open the door Senor open the door
am I taking crazy pills in Herat the
charger is ready I hear [ __ ] come on
computer
let's open the dang door okay there's
something I do out here why is this like
this
oh hey look at that
look who's too intelligent to breed now
you know what is that raucous settle
down okay Oh crappers hate those things
fucking-a oh he's crap jet jet Wow holy
crap did I get hurt
oh my god well I did not take that well
you know anyway what's the thing that I
could jump across right here oh my god
thank you sir
oh [ __ ]
okay let's take this a little easier
this time you know let's go a little
better as done where's the rest
something no there's more I know there's
more here a little [ __ ]
yep out you got me and maybe I'll just
say yeah you know so I can get this
thing real quick
I can do another little save right here
thank you thank you
hello oh [ __ ] it scared me hello here
room service is dead
I shall have some yeah yeah yeah okay
holy crap
take Adam
I guess I got them you know I guess I'm
pretty alright at this game out
she says okay okay a hat I have to bring
all those bottles I need help so badly
these levels it's like pretty insane
okay
yeah shot it right now oh don't mind if
I do
so what does that do oh they are not
going to like that
what how's this
by those mines
how do i okay can I save here oh no oh
my god I wish my pants
ow you [ __ ]
I have a lot of ammo so you know la
payday okay baby hurting myself I guess
not
this days so dumb
I don't even know warrants was to go
okay I make it a clear file path and I'm
just blind through here okay
okay I think I'm out of here wait where
the hell likes we going holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
up there
oh okay anything up later man I like to
describe this guy who literally has no
plan whatsoever he just like literally
here's a pathway guess I'm going to take
this one you know he really has not
planned us let me go over y'all women
you know yes I'm talking about baby
that's what I'm talking about okay
that's what I'm talking about that sweet
release of Jesus because of Jesus pretty
dope okay hit see what's going on here
[ __ ] make sure can any dis breath yes
[Music]
all right summit someone's here said
they had the pest
well this place is actually huge
very
nope
that sprays up you know five
this is so dope this is like really
unlike any half-light little I've ever
seen any more guys here
you've gotta be kidding me I don't even
know how that works okay going to save
this for sure because I'm not good at
jumping
yeah establishing connection the server
got good good good good
where are those [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I
thought I saved
yes yeah bad touch here I thought you
could take me on okay okay wait what's a
quick say button let me just see that
real quick so I don't have to keep on
doing that every seconds
okay wait
quick save quick save clicks a quick
save Eric nope go save f6 perfect
shake it I want that shotgun stuff here
we go baby
this music is pretty badass and the
music is pretty badass it
oh hell yeah baby I'm Tom Clark in this
[ __ ] okay
how you [ __ ] with me
oh babe baby you messing with the wrong
baby right here okay oh did you go nap
up on the job you went nuts up on the
job get out of my face
yes stupid barrel just stupid bear this
rock thought you could do so much I'll
just do a little head corners oh oh yeah
oh okay which is the one that shoots the
missile I don't think I have a rock wall
to doing
okay let me just see what this is
this is like a grenade launcher I don't
have a rocket launcher feel like I
should have that I know but I don't have
that this has to get my face is way too
dangerous
good blows O'Connor no Chinese said no
way these things way too dangerous okay
this chair just taken up room okay which
one is to go this way or this way only
one way to find out you know what I'm
saying
Wow Oh No
they call me the one on bad day okay I
really feel like should get a rocket
launcher on here you know wait through
the key selling order I gotta go in that
thing Wow okay let's do let's get a
grenade ready you know you never know
what you use I can add far
kind of say Belize
pl
um holy crap
maybe throw a can at it Oh what the heck
Oh Oh God up okay
[ __ ] wire okay here's the plan
okay okay yeah what the hell okay I did
not know be picking up that thing like
sex okay here this is how we do it
no no no no no oh my god like what does
a guy got to do around here don't like
eat a chicken sandwich okay okay it's a
new plan we just kind of throw a real
high up perfect but you like chicken
there you go okay adios muchachos Wow
but it's okay it's okay we got some help
here
[Music]
ándele what's black and white and should
be red all over
I don't know it's a good one odd I don't
really know okay all right just in the
nick of time huh
I can't tell if the laser system
guidance is on
Wow I really messed that up
[Music]
a little more health in here okay
okay I guess I'm going the other way now
don't even make sense these are another
guy here so there should be which is
more rocket vessel design
there's guys here I could taste it
what the hell
if I mess up a narrower millets whistle
or else we'll start off
myth says rock is so funny-looking can't
be going that way right hey this is
where I started maybe
okay hold up
if sex is for it is not crazy
just caution flying rocks but I don't
really know if this is
very strange
you know supposed to go back up
Oh better up okay I got into a pretty
bad lay there a couple times so I'm
going to reload this nobody knows which
way to really go nobody know whose baby
nobody knows the way true way to go I'm
just a scientist with the best Oh baby
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm just a
scientist this is way above my pay grade
baby yeah yeah oh no that's the end of
the that's the end of the game you know
one life to let about me I like to let
been a okay sure enough lipstick over
there yeah there's no way to get up
there afterwards
there's something strange here okay
maybe I'm I'm supposed to go right after
I got those emo you know maybe some new
opportunity opened up a lot of dead
bodies yeah yeah guys I'm really sorry
about this but it is what it is
oh yeah it's open up okay here we go
baby it's got a real gun
what the hell is that up great you
jumped off okay now that you stupid rock
now mr. primont welcome welcome
oh wow
okay see if we what the hell
they just bomb that kind of that they
did I can't come around there here we
got babies no sad just that okay f6s
that boy let's keep going bad bay rep
yes
Duke for and I'm what you think I want
to see you yes stupid thing Yap
okay what's going to spawn art from my
face now you know
what is it what's going to spawn great
and get some oxygen once in a while wow
this place looks like [ __ ] what am i
fine in here
prefer not to get my feet wet that's
like an option
when are we getting relief that's a good
question
Oh make schmuck now no no no I love this
bad boy
okay the tank is really hurting me Jesus
Christ
oh this is getting way too bloody for my
standard okay there's gotta be healthier
oh my god f6 this bad boy
oh my god dude this is like insane
now that's a squared alright so much
panic they killed everybody you know
it's scrapped that sad
puzzle here
that's American use this
and I'm the lone ranger I guess
right
perfect caromar that bad
I just feel like this is very like not
neutrally match holy crap
wow this is insane this is crazy train
over here any more hidden stuff
Wow this is Texas that make such a weird
noise someone opening up so man what the
hell is that here that they spawned it's
stupid Halen
you
I definitely look like I can't get it we
were there spun space and I enter with
the space varmint
Piang definitely can't go through there
nothing in there
I need to know what's going on over
there
where the aliens Texican aliens
whoo that one that close and actually
hit me Jesus
I hear crap going on and then more
spawning out you bet oh ah sucker I
whenever could save that guy who lets
autosave - a while ago not yeah
what the f
why is your so many on the side
okay it looks so much ammo
there goes nothing
Oh Oh Shay said
you
if we're going to ham it bro we're going
to have this whole like I know where are
you where are you yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's an automated turn I think
okay once examiner can I go through
there now
okay I gotta find out what my next thing
is prior to go up there and say what's
in here you're heading for the lambda
complex all right hell yeah I am I was
heading there myself so I wound up here
and she lost my nerve take one look
through that door and we'll see well I'm
going to wait out the catastrophe in
here if you intend to go on then I beg
of you they may lie for all our sake for
seed with extreme caution
yeah bad at scientists what do I hear
nothing Hannah's niak what the heck baby
take one look through that door tipping
creature call our sake proceed with
extreme caution we get a f6s bad boy
because lord knows what's over there of
course not
of course this is the only way through
and now to be honest I'm not really
surprised I'm just kind of tired can I
jump over that
okay I guess I can't I guess I cannot
you know good a scary Oh F six o'clock
okay look do it okay I didn't really
work too well that way go bye-bye oops
have sex act like this what the hell did
this guy do oh my god this guy got some
serious issues that work out
[Music]
that eyebrow
at 6:00
okay could I still not begin with holy
cannoli
[Applause]
[Music]
my god okay
say that oh my god
I'm Kylie's so where I got to go anyhow
with that
the LMF wants brows which is why you got
to give it your all
heck yeah
what does this do oh my god
they're not citizens I just
f six o'clock is go baby let's escape
growling banner let's just keep growing
no really how do you get out of here
right
I don't know what to help where I mean
was supposed to go
Jesus
city would nowhere which was that are
you going where is this just like a
free-for-all you know
hmm
visitors I'm exit
hell yeah it is okay got sprayed
soldiers the hell is this what is this
disgusting okay Tom I am cook
this the not yet okay like this the
wrong way but look through the best
thing I've seen all day
fascinating right and for the ammo thing
hey ok ok don't ok again done ok again
what the heck is that
hey where is it where is it
Wow so bad with this
okay anything like house
Oh God okay I guess at six o'clock
because I need help
nice
Oh No oh my god Linda okay I have six
o'clock not tuned to a hotwives but you
know I think we've all done better I
think we can all say we've had better
days okay be held in this building
there's no health and this whole thing
come on Brad I'll be done this to me
free oh my god finally someone who ain't
gotta yank trying to kill me - like now
I'm trying to get some help bro
well from the looks of it you got not
for the finer thing yes yes check this
out open Justin what hell yeah baby
oh my god
Oh baby I like what I say you must be
the guy the other side just been talking
about you sure piston soldiers off
something fierce can load somewhere
hangs on ammunition let the hands on a
mission I can't tell okay that's hang
animation and it really love everything
okay okay yeah
hell yeah I'm glad what is this well
you've got a whole one name where you
seen the other one it was like one okay
just kidding okay we're doing a real
save here I can I can I ask you the same
your friend though help where is that a
canny low health and Eli help okay I
guess I wasn't gracious enough with the
help this is dope well
ah out
okay brow take it some more house or
everything actually recess it's kind of
annoying to get all this [ __ ] you hear
something now I don't hear anything
Laser guy back and I just finally gone
okay
not exactly so I'm doing now
okay
weird
don't apply on top I do i no way what is
that I'm doing it then I got to get in
that building with the get over there
with the sniper all right yeah this
yeah
okay here we go
let the Pops of [ __ ] right yeah sure
at 6 o'clock we're about to Pop's and
[ __ ]
another guy there isn't
take a black ops team
why did electric a
okay
[Music]
si
what the heck I'm going to burn up
hello sir
well haba haba and I go there
oh hell yeah baby yeah the man now
smoking okay I think it's got to do here
feel like somewhere else I got to go now
lahter now
that might be where I got to go yep six
o'clock if you don't know what is down
there by Bay
great let them fight it out
yes stupid guy
ah okay
look a new planet is a run through
open this door [ __ ] yeah open it
to our baby
holy crap
oh my god
they said
that
hello mark
I just know bad with this weapon
okay keep going
f 6 o'clock baby holy cannoli hello
Lincoln Ally Saudi on this one going to
go shotty how
okay well that's crap so
right now I guess it's open enema
missiles in this encampment okay well we
know where we gotta go okay let's just
say it that way we know exactly where we
gotta go change this already we'll end
it here today I don't know I don't know
what I'm feeling like you know just
don't know oh dang
taking like ten years to load this bad
boy how big is this one what's that
noise
it's in it
oh my god
a lot of them
now I can actually see
okay well I'm just here good spot very
handsome
let's all be happy and grateful for
where we are in life okay
thank you thank you um yeah and thank
you and yet psychobabble Horia that's a
go babble Aria okay
hit apply psychobabble and I don't know
maybe um Lou will finish this game for
the first time in like two years
I just thought you know just just lost I
know what's going okay um I'm just
nervous tension I think we have another
one after this oh my god if you're
watching this like it's pretty sad
there's gotta be better ways to do your
entertainment in this world in awe
there's gotta be better ways you know
like and I like I stare at pennies in
the corner and I'm like and I like okay
oh yeah where's this pretty cool part
what is it annoys
and I don't know that noises but I'm
going to go oh my god that okay right
fine okay let's see what's in here
absolutely nothing okay
what was it was it f6 yeah that's
excellent
okay good
how fast the noise let's just let this
calm down law but you know anyway let's
just make this way you know okay I guess
I guess you're not sneaking the clay
time soon
anyways thanks for thanks for clearing
out the field you know Jesus I'm getting
soaked in here I'm getting soaked in
here well what the sound go house weird
just incredible okay let's see here good
boy what the heck is this oh my god
it's so weird that was not an ally game
before my just gone up what is that oh
there bunch of zombies yeah Dan get him
from here it's worth every penny you
know it's worth every penny hello sir
so what is this that looks like that
does sound I have been God wait ah I got
like some stuff in my ears
what the heck yes do it wait credit yes
okay shredder that's weird
okay I'm guessing have to go back up
that yellow thing was so weird I'm still
like getting over that you know
oh my god is that
this is thing is all madama we do not
hurt okay
and it does
I'll never really now
okay obviously waste
I'm out here and mo okay what is that
how's that
Wow Wow should not have use a Timelord
there I was eating an arm hey that's my
stop did that kind of used up that
squeak did that stupid squeak is so cute
okay I'll make it I'll make it buddy
this is this gas thing Oh
close sex oh right there yeah are you
talking MA
you think you're clever
how do you feel with the shotgun in this
guy's channel oh there's pretty cool
though oh haha okay let me get some of
that weight oh you don't tell me what my
palate I tell you what about it okay son
around we are one
purpose on this house over there okay
now it's useless and ladies give me what
I want
[Music]
all right
I'll make an account I so badly
okay
so this guy wants to mess first I think
holy cannoli
sir guy still there yeah
pretty light wide range
are they telling them a
how's that
okay okay no one's coming here
heck yes I just think it's really [ __ ]
I shower without clothes
okay have a seat actor right crap looks
like I do
oh crap right at AMS I'm not going to
make it we share the one no one
does that have sworn there was another
wait crap won't you go back in there
oh my god Kyle oh it previously yeah
okay because I should not have used that
much house
get up just count
you
getting run out
okay Lucy I can do that satellite
longtail hmm we're just weekend
here's a better way
listen rocket launcher
a logical logical Ocala
okay
f6 please get it boys I get it yeah what
is that
he said sniper
but there's so much fun fired you think
automating cat
you
Oh God
I definitely don't anymore
Ethan her
how
yeah I got a lotta Lotta baby
you
okay there we go see here and six
o'clock the wind blowing are tripping
out there
yeah on my face oil
head-on
it's not here nothing intersect all
these places there's so much room here
now okay at least it's a low one here oh
I definitely felt something going on how
they yell security system anything else
here now them lose that pink out those
like a pancake stuck the waterfall it's
not it's not just me okay where is the
time thing so if there's something
retired right here like a pure good
action one just soda machines out you
know throw this right at it
hmm okay loading one of the squeeze in
your area nobody else
Oh my cannolis oh my god I can always
oh my sleeping always
holy hell
you see
oh my god what was that
let's see we go get that one yes yes yes
yes come on Batman right in the honey
maker ha ha ha ha Wow
okay now that is a nice way to kind of
communication that's okay how
like I've been going this way
they make [ __ ] even go that way because
it's like so broader over
authorized person now okay can't go that
way I guess I got to go that we're long
way in here no okay
swords take 2 o'clock
Oh Oh
okay I can't come on
what the heck okay wait
but
what is going on here okay okay okay
I think I know I think I have to
actually jump off of it and land on that
squishy thing which is really horrifying
okay at six o'clock okay
maybe I should wear in a little bit if I
get as bad one
if I do this oh I gotta I got it
there we go nope okay I have ruled that
one out I have really ruled that one out
okay again get good
Oh
okay that's how this one
it seems more like real life bad way in
the toilet you conscious stayed quiet
oh okay what what I don't know what the
purpose was this okay
can I get out Hannah Graham stuck I'm
stuck this needs to go in here
stupid animal
okay we're getting somewhere
surely it's aware but holy cannoli
okay
Oh
right
okay your turn this time again
okay I don't like that it's not cheap
exactly exactly
episodes of class 10
ah
rarely bloody
Doucette rate has to Sonic
okay but this is necessary somewhere
sure let's just do that in it okay but
we go back inside a little hold on yeah
and just keep the class scientific let's
keep it interesting you know which hole
should I go on this one short hi nice
and warm in here you know okay let's say
yeah here now they say miss sure don't
that beat all
you're dr. freeman aren't you yes well
the good news is you just ran into the
only guy for about half a mile who has
lambda codes bad news if these guys are
blocking the frickin goal line
I say we do this nice and quiet they
look the spective enough okay Oh baby
hold on sir what do I got that down
lock it up they're coming out to
extraction point
okay up crap fly my ass
at okay
oh my god sir you crazy he's crazy
starter down here oh my god this guy is
thrice a oh my god is so not proud that
we're in the same room has done when you
are
but he's locked me in here
all right what's happen now so I was
just out here
open now
right
Oh
brap brap instead
okay God new plan just straight up just
straight up
well even know whether they're going to
spot it should be a little easier
okay fry this dude his next
okay okay
Oh
now get your heart pumping ah yeah [ __ ]
after you good circuit I'll tell you
what that could have been a lot worse
wait what
oh my god all right
she said the hell is that oh my god I
went with this guy
brother sings to run after me
[Music]
yes definite animal
go to the breakthrough van Han
okay I knew with these guys
how did
hmm
how are we going to get out of this mess
enough
does anyone know
Wow
like that I'm trying
enter
[Music]
still there yesterday
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
now well well well
[Music]
con grout on bro
I'm proud
yeah yeah oh crap
I'll be
where is it where is he
[Music]
oh my god I can't even pull the trigger
they get him yes you gotta know
far far far
[Music]
[Music]
no okay
cast alarm
[Music]
okay we did it
[Music]
okay let's go get out of here
[Music]
[Music]
dude this
[Music]
crowd
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
what's that
again look around okay
[Music]
on vehicles at door right
[Music]
I'm browning denim
[Music]
eyebrow
[Music]
now that
and then
um
[Music]
in fact
[Music]
Hey
I guess
[Music]
shirt off the right air
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
which really
sorry go back now
little perplexed as to wherever go
[Music]
you
hmm
angry
ah
[Music]
- for there
[Music]
turning over here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I really have no idea
[Music]
why I was twice i gay guys [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
but it kind of be that door
just given bomb a catalyst
[Music]
you
[Music]
count bro
here big propane tank
what is that aiming at yes
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
and outer-image
there we
[Music]
okay finally rather than that finally
one doesn't annoying higher up great
great master this no I didn't say it